there are over a million space objects
in the solar system
ranging from tiny asteroids to gas
giants
some of them have been studied
sufficiently well while our knowledge
about
others is rather sparse there are many
objects
still waiting to be discovered and today
we will talk about one of the coldest
darkest and remotest
places in the solar system the planetoid
sedna
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
but before we get to that i'd like to
remind you that we're also in telegram
there is some exciting latest updates in
the world of science and space
the perseverance rovers landing on mars
for example
sounds from mars and the first panoramic
snapshots can be checked out there
you will also get notifications about
the latest videos on our youtube channel
feel free to subscribe if you haven't
yet this way you will definitely not
miss our latest videos
and now back to the story
in the late 20th century there was a
major breakthrough in studying remote
corners of our solar system
3 55 celestial objects have been
discovered beyond neptune's orbit since
the 1990s
most of them are not very large bodies
made up of water ice and frozen gases
like
methane and nitrogen trans-neptunian
objects
form conventional areas around the sun
like the kuiper belt
the scattered disk and supposedly the
oort cloud
the kuiper belt encompasses the solar
system as a large ring at distances from
30 to 55 astronomical units from the
center
it resembles the asteroid belt only it
is 20 times as wide
and up to 200 times as massive
the kuiper belt consists mainly of
debris remaining after the formation of
the solar system
although it does contain rather large
objects as well
like pluto sharon haumea makimaki and
other planetoids
the borders of the scattered disk are
more blurred
it consists of objects whose perihelion
is over 35 astronomical units
and whose orbits are elongated or lie
closely to the ecliptic plane
most of these objects are not very large
and are quite gravitationally unstable
most of the scattered discs objects
orbits are posited to have been
predefined by neptune
with the latter having expelled them
from the inner layers of the solar
system
acting as some kind of a gravitational
cannon
the largest space object in this area in
space
is the planetoid aerys there is one more
object worthy of our attention
it's a small planetoid called sedna
that's what we'll talk about today
this dwarf planet was discovered on the
14th of november 2003 by american
astronomers michael brown
chadwick trujillo and david rabinowitz
at the time of discovery it was thought
to be the second largest object of the
kind
beaten only by pluto however very soon
it found itself in the fifth place among
all known trans-neptunian objects
coming after eris haumea and makamaki
as revealed by calculations of sedna's
orbit around the sun
its trajectory is extremely elongated
its perihelion is 76 astronomical units
which is two and a half times the radius
of neptune's average orbit
sedna's aphelion is 942 astronomical
units away from the sun
thus the planetoid must be one of the
remotest and apparently the coldest
objects in our system detected so far
that is actually what has earned it its
name one of its discoveries
michael brown has dubbed it after an
inuit goddess of sea animals
sedna completes a full orbit around the
center of the solar system with an
approximately eleven and a half thousand
years
when discovered it was 89.6 astronomical
units away from the sun
this is approximately twice the distance
to pluto
sydney is now on its way to meet the sun
it is expected to reach its perihelion
around the year 2076.
however the sun will not be visible as a
disk from the dwarf planet's surface
even from the closest point of its orbit
when watched from sedna our sun will
look like a very bright star
with a luminosity much higher than that
of the moon in our sky
sedna's diameter is about a thousand
kilometers
it is only 40 percent that of pluto and
slightly smaller than sharon
unfortunately there are no moons around
sedna that is why it is hardly possible
to gauge its mass with a high degree of
accuracy
as it is it is estimated at one to ten
percent
that of our moon in plain exact numbers
it could be anything from eight point
three times ten to the power of twenty
kilograms
to seven times ten to the power of
twenty one kilograms
only a special expedition to the dwarf
planet's environs would yield much more
precise
data sedna's rotation period
is about 10 hours with a rotation axis
tilting to the orbital plane at almost
degrees the planetoid's bright red
surface
reflects around 32 percent of the light
shed on it
spectral analysis shows the dwarf
planet's outer layers
are mostly made up of water ice and
frozen gases
methane ethane and nitrogen prolonged
ultraviolet radiation treatments of the
hydrocarbon sludge on the surface
produced tholins organic polymers
containing nitrogen it is these
substances that give the planetoid
surface its bright color
sedna will be comparatively close to the
sun for about 200 years
in this time its surface temperature
will rise to 35.6 kelvin
or 237.6 degrees
celsius below zero this will make some
of the gases shrouding the planetoid
evaporate
which in its turn will greatly rarify
the atmosphere
however the most optimistic estimates
show that its density will be 70
000 times less than that of the earth at
the very least
when the planetoid hits the escape
trajectory from the sun
its temperature will rather dramatically
fall to a few degrees
above absolute zero it is thought that
unlike on triton
pluto and darius there are no methane
snow precipitations on sedna on account
of its low temperatures
even though sedna was discovered almost
30 years ago
scientists still don't have a unanimous
opinion about it
one of the things on which they don't
agree with each other is where it
belongs
that is whether it is part of the
scattered disc or the oort cloud
the oort cloud is a hypothetical area in
the solar system
lying beyond the scattered disc and
stretching for up to a hundred thousand
astronomical units away from the sun
its borders are rather blurred this part
of the solar system looks like a
spherical cloud
made up of a great number of comet
nuclei
it is from here that comets with
enormous orbital periods of tens of
thousands of years take off as it were
the hill sphere or the sun's
gravitational sphere of influence
is considered the cloud's outer boundary
the sphere's radius is about one light
year
sedna's orbit is so elongated that as it
travels in the solar system
it traverses the entire area of the
scattered disk
and approaches the inner boundary of the
oort cloud
some scientists believe that the object
is too far from the main planets in the
solar system
and so their gravitational pull is
negligible
besides sedna was estimated never to
have come
close enough to neptune to have had its
orbit in any way affected
these clues lead us to believe that
sedna is much
closer to the oort cloud objects even
though most of its orbit
finds itself within the scattered disk
as sedna is remote and barely studied
there are theories awaiting further
confirmation
for example modeling the process of
radioactive decay
suggests the possibility of there being
a liquid ocean in the planetoid's
interior
calculations of the trajectories of
several transneptunian objects with
elongated orbits
including sedna give grounds to
believing that there is an undiscovered
massive object
located beyond the boundaries of the
kuiper belt
data collection is underway and its
results will either confirm or repudiate
these assumptions
even though sedna is listed in nasa's
program of the solar system exploration
no spacecraft is planned to be sent to
it in the nearest decades
perhaps it will be paid due scientific
attention
when the distance between the dwarf
planet and the earth is considerably
smaller
sedna may well be a really remote
celestial object
but there are some even further than
that out there in the solar system
for example the object 2018 ag-37
also known as far far out was spotted
132 astronomical units away from the sun
it is the remotest object in the solar
system that can be observed directly
interestingly while following their
orbits
some celestial objects already known to
us may recede from the sun
much further for example the ophelian of
the comet
c1992 j1 spotted by david rabinovitz in
is 3650 astronomical units
this means that it will take 78 000
years to complete a full orbit
there are many comets of this kind with
elongated orbits and a mind-boggling
orbital period
that are still waiting to be discovered
who knows
one of you might be able to do that at
some point
dear friends we do our best to make our
videos informative and great to watch
that is why your support means a lot to
us by hitting the like button you help
the channel to grow
if you'd like to give us some ideas
about what other objects in the solar
system we could tell you about
feel free to tell us in the comments and
also there are some latest news about
space on our channel and telegram that
you can check out
while waiting for our new videos let's
keep in touch
[Music]
you